si vous avez l'impression des débarqués
dans un dessin animé japonais c'est
normal le festival fait la part belle au
cosplay c'est-à-dire au fleix d'incarner
un personnage de manga ou de jeu vidéo
avec des costumes parfois entièrement
créés à la main c'est un faune tiré de
l'univers médiéval fantastique
donc je prend comme référence le monde
de narnia et
il a été fait en plusieurs semaines à
l'origine de ce festival il y à gilles
habitants de chérisy et imprimeur de
mangas depuis une vingtaine d'années je
suis allé plusieurs fois au japon visité
des imprimeries voir les principaux
éditeurs et puis deuxièmement je suis en
fin de carrière donc j'ai un réseau qui
est énorme au niveau des éditeurs des
mangaka du japon donc j'ai décidé de
ramener mon réseau a choisi c'est donc
logiquement que le festival met en avant
de jeunes auteurs de mangas comme à chin
à 26 ans il arrive à vivre de cet art
même si cela reste compliqué en france
comparé au japon j'essaie de toucher à
tout en fait le domaine tout ce qui est
des dessins illustrations voilà vraiment
de tout et donc j'ai grâce à sa grâce
au manga mes illustrations j'arrive à en
vivre il a d'ailleurs réalisé la fiche
du festival cette année
un festival qui met à l'honneur le japon
sous toutes ses formes comme le yoga
colle une danse née dans les années 50
c'est quelque chose de très enjoué de
très coloré de très dynamique dont qui
casse un peu avec l'image des arts
traditionnels japonais on al'impression
nation l'impression que ça va être des
mouvements lents que ça va être quelque
chose de cannes de très encadrée si le
monde du manga séduit surtout les plus
jeunes les organisateurs ont réussi à
attirer d'autres générations cette année
grâce au personnage de la guerre des
étoiles venu leur en mettre plein les
yeux
[Musique]